scp-173 versus scp-106  the sinister neck snapping sculpture  versus the old man with a plan to  torture you forever this is an  incredibly close call with both being  immensely powerful anomalies scp-173 is  one of the few creatures  scp-682 is terrified of and its ability  to snap necks with little effort and  incredible speed make it a formidable  foe but 106 may just have the edge here  firstly we don't even know if 106 has  eyelids so he might not even blink  secondly his powers make him able to  phase through and able to corrupt solid  objects which scp-173 may be vulnerable  to and most compelling of all there's no  telling what scp-173 would make of being  trapped in the old man's pocket  dimension for all these reasons we think  106 would walk away with the title belt  this time